تتمثل رؤية 2030 بأكملها في ضمان
أننا نبني القدرات التي نحن على استعداد
لتطويرها ، ولا يمكننا انتظار قاعدة التطوير البطيئة ،
لذلك نحتاج إلى التأكد
من استعدادنا لوجود
مبادرات تكميلية للغاية ، ومبادرات IAF
، والصفقات التي عقدناها
مع  نحن  يكشف أن لدينا مع الصين مع
اليابان مع دول أخرى كلها
مكملة لبعضها البعض في الواقع
سوف يكمل بعضها البعض ،
وسوف تستثمر IAF في
شركة الصناعات العسكرية السعودية سامي
التي ستستثمر بعد ذلك أيضًا ومع
بعض العقود التي  لقد
وقعنا مع الولايات المتحدة ، لذا فإن كل ذلك
مكمل ، فنحن نبني القدرات
بينما نتحدث ، وبينما نمضي قدمًا ،
نقوم بإصلاح المحرك أثناء التحليق
لأننا نحتاج حقًا إلى القيام بذلك ،
فهناك الكثير الذي نحتاج إلى التقاطه و
نحن نفعل ذلك بينما نتحرك
ونطير ثلاثة رؤساء تنفيذيين عالميين جاءوا
إليّ وقالوا بعد أن أعلن ولي العهد
أنه يريد القضاء على الإسلام الراديكالي ،
فقد اعتبروا ذلك علامة على أن
الاعتدال يحدث في البلاد
وإشارة للمستثمرين الأجانب  تعال ،
هل هناك علاقة مباشرة
بين الاثنين في رأيك أعتقد أن
هناك علاقة مباشرة بين
ذلك والترحيب بالاستثمارات التي مع
التنمية الاقتصادية مع الاستمرار  إلى
المستوى التالي
أعتقد أن الإسلام المعتدل هو عقيدتنا
ثقافتنا أن نسيجنا الاجتماعي
اختطف لعقود للأسف
كان كذلك والآن نعود إلى
الإسلام المعتدل ونريد أن نتأكد من
أن هذا لا يزال المحرك
الأساس وراء ما نحن  تقوم به ومن
حيث الإصلاح الاقتصادي والإصلاح الاجتماعي